-I'm sorry. I--
-Shut up.
I don't wanna
lose you again.
We're going for drinks.
You can join us if you want,
but I think you have
better things to do.
He lives downstairs.
I don't wanna
to make it complicated.
Oh, sometimes
the best relationships
are complicated.
Did you forget something?
I did.
Good night.
Why shouldn't we stay here,
where we're free of
the False God's petty tests?
Together, we can bring
the Truth of the Morningstar
to the masses.
And you'll rule beside me,
as my queen.
I wish I were worthy
of such a station.
Oh, Lilith.
Give yourself to me,
and I will make you worthy.
Hey! Stop! No!
Virginia Miller,
you little idiot.
That was seriously not cool.
Oh.
Marcus, let's go.
I'm really glad
that I decided
to invest in your business,
David.
That is a really
lovely thing to say.
"And I'm so glad
you did, Patrick.
You really helped to turn it
into the success it is."
A bold claim.
Thank you.
For what?
I've never done that before
with a guy.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, and…
I was getting
a little scared
that I was gonna
let you leave here
without us having done that,
so thank you…
for…
making that happen for us.
Stand up.
Okay.
Alright,
here's what we're gonna do.
Get into like a general
fighting position.
Just, yeah, leg out.
-Right.
-Kind of in an L. Arm out.
Here.
Then you want that arm out.
Yeah, there you go.
Then you kind of position--
You wanna put your hands
on my hips?
No. No, I'm correcting
your stance.
Look, this move
is really hard.
If you don't get it
at first, don't feel bad--
Holy shit, Sam.
That was amazing.
What do you--
Sensei Sam.
You know, this may be the
best date I've ever been on.
Really? Cause, technically,
this isn't a date.
Right, not a date.
And that was not a kiss.
Yeah.
That means a lot to me,
Alina.
You mean a lot.
To everyone.
Not many people surprise me,
Miss Starkov.
Seriously, Poppins…
how are you still standing?
I think I'm crazy.
I think you're surprisingly
sane, considering.
Look…
I know what it feels like.
Feels like
you can't find your--
Are you sure?
Yes.
Okay.
I just had to check.
I have a very good
imagination,
so I just had to be sure
this is real.
Anne, I have to know,
do you truly
have feelings for me?
Really?
That's it?
You're just gonna walk away
like this never happened?
Well, that's what
professionals do, right?
Sarah, I just had
the best day of my life.
John B, you're gonna
blow our covers.
Look, I don't care
about my cover, Sarah.
I don't care
if my friends find out,
or your boyfriend
with his frosted tips.
Look, yesterday, I didn't
even know who you were.
And today, I'm like…
Sarah Cameron.
And honestly,
in my limited experience,
that's rare.
That's like…
Like eclipse rare.
Like a blind person
seeing colour
for the first time rare,
or like Bigfoot evidence,
or the northern lights.
Look, I can't pretend
like this isn't real,
like this didn't happen.
-I'm sorry. I--
-Shut up.
I can't pretend either.
Hey, man, get a room.
Did you mean it?
Of course, I meant it.
-I can't… I can't do this.
-Okay.
I understand.
I don't…
I don't wanna
lose you again.
I'm confused.
This is confusing me.